- [Host] We're very happy to
kick off the morning session
with a talk on developing resilience,
how to be inspired when
you're just really tired.
Matthew Verscheure,
is the Director of
Training for Homebridge,
a non-profit agency
providing IHSS services
to over 13,000 clients in San Francisco,
and Dennis Gallegos is a Training
Specialist at Homebridge.
They're gonna tell us a little
bit more about their program
and some of the fantastic
things that they're doing.
So Matthew and Dennis, please come on up.
- Good morning, everybody.
If you're visiting,
welcome to the Bay Area.
I hope you're having a wonderful time
here in this great city,
and it's not raining,
which it's been doing
for a long long time.
They mentioned that Dennis
and I are from Homebridge
And Homebridge is an organization
based here in San Francisco.
We provide what is called
"Contract Mode IHSS Services."
In California, every county has the option
to contract with a private agency
to provide IHSS services to individuals
who, for whatever reason,
can't manage their own work,
or don't have someone that they
want to be their caregiver,
or have chronic substance abuse,
mental health issues, also
developmental disabilities.
One of the cornerstones at Homebridge
is that we have always,
since the organization began in 1994,
provided training to our workers.
We were committed, the board is committed,
that the home care providers
should be trained in understanding
the needs of individuals
that require care.
In 2010, the city and
county of San Francisco
awarded Homebridge a contract
to expand our training,
which Dennis actually
developed at the onset,
to expand that training and offer it
to all of the IHSS providers
in San Francisco County.
There are about 20,000 recipients of IHSS
in just the city and
county of San Francisco,
and there are about 19,000
registered providers.
So our trainings are available
to all of those providers at no charge,
and over the course of any given year
we offer training to about 1,000 people,
so we just kind of touch
on that surface of that.
As they mention, Homebridge alone,
we serve 13,000 people, 12,000
in San Francisco County,
and about 100 in San Mateo County.
So those are the only two
counties in California
that currently have
Contract Mode Services.
Another new business
that Homebridge is doing
is working with Sutter Health,
and we provide transitional care services
to individuals who would otherwise
present in the emergency
room and be admitted when
they really could just use
some short term home care,
and we contract out on a 24 hour,
seven days a week basis
to provide that service
to Sutter Emergency Rooms in the city.
So that's kind of a little
synopsis of what we do.
Dennis and I thought, "How do
we want to start this out?"
And one of the things that
Homebridge has been doing
is we created a video to recruit people
to be home care providers for us.
We employ, we should, I should say,
employ about 450 home care providers.
We are struggling with a very good economy
and a minimum wage that's going up.
So we are down about 100 workers,
so we are aggressively trying
to recruit qualified people to do this.
So we created a video about a year ago,
and we thought we'd start with that.
Am I doing this right?
There we go.
Oh, I should say,
we don't have any disclosures,
with the exception of,
I'm wearing new bifocals
because I turned 50 in November,
and I'm a junior member of AARP.
So that's my little
snippet for the morning.
Anyway, we wanted to start with this video
because it's some of
our staff talking about
what motivates them to do
this very difficult work
that they're being asked to do,
so we'll start with that this morning.
(video playing off-microphone)
Alright.
I keep forgetting about that part.
(clapping)
I'm actually going to
turn it over to Dennis.
I wanted to make one other comment.
One thing that we have done,
because burnout is what we're going
to talk about a little bit next,
our providers work
pretty much by themselves
out in the community.
Last fall, with the help
of some financial support,
we were able to mobilize
our workforce with iphones
and they now have an app that has
everything they need
regarding their schedules,
their client's care plan,
and direct communication
with their case worker
for that individual while
they're out in the field,
so there's no delay.
It's real time support to those workers.
Part of the problem is getting
some of our older workers
to embrace the idea of
using a smart phone.
And that's been some trickiness.
But that has really changed
the way they feel supported,
and to keep them inspired in
what they're doing out there,
because if you're out
there with no support
and no one to talk to, you
can easily become uninspired.
So, I'm gonna turn it over to
Dennis now for a few minutes.
- Good morning, everybody.
Nice to see your smiley faces.
Are you happy?
Pharrell made you all happy, right?
I mean, that song gets you happy.
I like that song for that reason.
Alright, well, so we're talking about,
there we go.
Before we start talking about inspiration,
I wanted to talk about burnout.
And this is my friend, Eric,
and you can see in his
first picture there,
he's a little stressed,
his hair is sticking up.
He's fortunate enough to have hair.
And then when we asked him
to pose for the picture,
he said "Hey I'm just too burnt out,
I can't even do this."
And I'm sure some of us
have had that experience,
where we're just at the point where,
you know what, I just can't do it.
I just can't.
So, before I talk about being inspired,
I wanna talk about burnout,
and most of us know what it is,
and if you're experiencing burnout,
you probably don't need
me to tell you what it is.
But I'm gonna tell you about it anyway.
So, what is burnout?
Well, there was a great paper
that I read by Christina Maslach,
I think that's how I pronounce her name,
and Susan E. Jackson.
And basically they define three very,
three central constructs
of what is burnout.
The first one is emotional exhaustion.
You go home at night,
and you're just fatigued,
you're tired, you just
drop down on the couch,
you pop open a cold one,
and you just don't care what's on TV.
That's how you feel.
And I'm sure some of
us had that experience.
The other one is depersonalization.
Negative or very detached feelings.
You just, you stop caring, you know?
That person becomes just a patient,
they're not a person anymore.
We don't care, we really
just don't care about
the outcome of what we're doing.
We're just putting in the time.
And then, reduced
personal accomplishments.
You just can't get any satisfaction.
You heard in the video,
the folks talking about how
they like go home at night
and have a smile on their face,
they feel good about helping someone.
Well, when you're burnt
out, you don't get that.
It's not there.
So, the other thing about burnout,
is some causes of it,
and when I did this research
for this presentation,
I've discovered that many
people have many reasons
of why they're burnt out.
And I'm sure some of you have
your own personal reason,
if you've experienced burnout,
or are feeling burnt out at this moment.
But these ten appealed to me,
and the first one is losing,
and I'm gonna actually
personalize this for you.
Losing sight of one's
values and or priorities.
So, I became a trainer at
Homebridge about 11 years ago,
and it was because I was really,
when I saw the job
advertisement for a Trainer,
I was like "This is what I
love to do! I wanna do this!"
And over time I began to lose sight
of that's what I really enjoyed doing.
Allowing others' expectations
to determine how you spend your time.
I got to a point where at Homebridge,
I was being asked to do, just
multiple, multiple trainings,
and I was just doing them.
I was just like a little robot.
I never once said "Wait a
minute, I can't keep doing this,
this isn't helpful to me right now."
Allowing issues to become
bigger than they really are.
So, I discovered that I
was paying more attention
to my students using their
cell phones in the classroom
than I was trying to teach them
the lessons that they needed
to become home care workers.
Overlooking the importance
of the three "R's,"
rest, relaxation, and rejuvenation.
Just not doing anything for myself
to reinvigorate myself.
Not going to the gym, not going for walks,
not spending time with my friends,
not even sitting down and
having a glass of wine at night.
Failing to care for yourself.
And, you know, this is
the number one problem
with a lot of us who do care giving,
is that we don't take care of ourselves.
We're good at taking
care of everybody else,
but when it comes to
taking care of ourselves,
we drop the ball.
Adding to your to do
list without deleting.
Yes, there's always
more to do, always more,
taking on more, and more, and more.
Forgetting to express gratitude.
You know, just realizing
"God, I got a great job,
you know, I work in an amazing city,"
you know, not being able to
even think about that type of,
think those type of thoughts.
Overlooking the importance of humor.
What I noticed, was that when I,
one of the things, techniques
I like to use in teaching
is telling jokes.
And I noticed suddenly
that I would think about,
"I should tell my students a joke today,
nah, I don't, I don't have it.
I just don't wanna talk about it."
So I lost my sense of humor, basically.
Getting stuck in a rut.
Just doing the same work
over and over and over again,
you're just going in
and putting in the time.
And then, the last one,
forgetting to go back to the beginning.
And that, I think is an important one,
and that's an important cause of burnout,
and that is something I'm gonna
talk about in a few minutes.
But before I do that,
I wanna talk about why burnout
is such a bad thing for us.
Because one, it's got some
pretty negative effects.
A Mayo Clinic study in 2012 found
that 45.4 percent of physicians
experience one symptom of burnout.
And this one was very startling,
Female physicians have
twice the suicide rate
of females in the general population.
Overall job satisfaction for physicians
hovers around 50 percent.
One in five nurses plan
to leave their current job
within the next year,
according to one study.
And then, in the hospitals
where you had higher
patient ratios to nurses,
basically, you had a higher
sense of job dissatisfaction
and higher patient mortalities.
Some other thing about burnout
is its extremely costly, very costly.
You know, we're training people,
everybody has to get trained
when they get into the job,
and within a year, they're gone.
And so a lot of money is spent
just rehiring, recruiting, and
retraining those individuals
only to see that they disappear
and are no longer part of your workforce.
And then, related to home care,
700 representatives from
700 homecare companies
participated in a 2015 benchmark study,
which is published
annually by Homecare Plus,
and basically what they found
was that 61.6 percent turnover rate,
and that was the highest recorded
since they began the study in 2010.
At Homebridge, this is a
real fight that we have,
constantly having to
recruit home care providers,
train them, and then we lose them.
And there's a number of
factors, but one of the factors
is caring for people is really hard work.
And so, the challenge is
how do we stay inspired when,
often the odds are stacked up against us?
So we have to look for inspiration!
And where do we find that inspiration?
For some of us, we might take
it from one of these folks.
We would consider these,
maybe, our spiritual leaders.
You know?
And I'm sure you recognize all
those lovely faces up there,
I don't need to tell you who they are.
But for some of us, maybe we
don't relate to the spiritual.
Instead, we relate to
somebody like Stephen Curry,
or Muhammad Ali, Picasso, Maya Angelou.
And, you know, these
are the type of people
that we can turn to when
we're looking for inspiration,
and what's really interesting,
we may just turn to someone
like our Special Olympian.
She may inspire us.
So it's important when we're looking for
resilience in our work, where
can we find the inspiration?
Sometimes it might just be in
the person that we're caring for.
When I was doing the
research I also asked Google,
"Google, who inspired Pablo Picasso?"
And what Google told me,
was it was his father who inspired him.
His father was a painter
and a drawing teacher.
Also, he got inspiration from two artists
that were at the time, relatively unknown.
So he found his inspiration in others.
Mother Teresa says she found
her inspiration in a calling.
A call within a call is where
she got her inspiration,
and then she began her work,
taking care of the sick and the poor.
Muhammad Ali at the age of 12,
had his bicycle stolen from him,
and when he was talking
to the policeman about it,
he said that he wanted
to go beat up the thief,
and the policeman said to him,
"Well, you need to learn how
to box if you want to do that."
So, Muhammad Ali got
his inspiration to box
from someone stealing his bicycle.
I like to think,
"What would have happened to Muhammad Ali
if nobody'd stolen his bicycle?"
And Rosa Parks, she's one of my heroes.
Rosa Parks, people have always said,
"Well, Rosa Parks refused
to get up out of her seat,
because she was tired
from a long day of work,"
and really what she said is,
"I wasn't tired physically, no,
the only tired I was,
was tired of giving in."
So she found her
inspiration within herself.
She was just too tired of
taking crap from people.
So, we need our inspiration
to keep moving forward,
to not be burnt out, right?
So, where do we find it?
Well, I ask you, think about this:
Why did you come to the work?
Why are you doing what you're doing?
Now, lots of reasons.
For some of us, it's to change lives.
Often in the caregiving field,
we wanna try and change somebody's life.
We wanna provide hope
to someone who maybe is
feeling a little hopeless.
We definitely wanna make a difference.
We all hope that our work
will make a difference.
We want to make the world a better place,
or improve the life of others.
Maybe it's to provide a cure,
or put a smile on a face.
And others?
Why did you come to this work?
Ask yourself that.
We want to go back to
the beginning, folks.
We wanna ask ourselves
over and over again,
when we're feeling those
feelings of burnout,
"Why am I here? Why am I doing
this? What's my purpose?"
Because, how can we be inspired
when we're tired?
That's a tough one.
But what I believe,
and what I wanna teach you today,
is that inspiration equals resilience.
We become inspired,
resilience will develop.
And I have actually proven that to myself,
that's why I'm sharing this with you.
It's the inspiration
that ignites what I call
the fire of purpose.
But we have to go back to,
"What's the reason we came to this work?"
Because maybe what's happening to us
when we're experiencing
those feelings of burnt out,
being tired, is we're forgetting
to go back to the beginning.
We got inspired to start doing
the work that we're doing.
Something inspired us to say,
"Hey, I'm gonna be a nurse,
I'm gonna be a doctor,
I'm gonna be a social worker,
I'm gonna do case management,
I'm gonna do the work that I'm doing
with the people that I care for."
This is what we did, and
this is what we were doing,
before the burnout showed up.
So, where we began,
is where we're gonna find the inspiration.
So, just, you know,
take a few minutes, right
now, to reflect on this.
Why did you come to the work?
What made you choose it?
What were you trying to accomplish?
And as you reflect upon that,
ask yourself "Where does
my inspiration come from?
What qualities do I
have to inspire myself?"
This is where we begin.
So I'm gonna conclude my topic
just giving you my story,
and show you how this works.
So for the past 11 years,
I've been teaching,
I've been a trainer at Homebridge,
training home care providers.
Many of them come to us who
have been family caregivers,
and that's it.
They don't have a lot of experience.
Some of them have no experience.
And with the exception
of a few alterations,
I have been teaching the same course
three weeks out of the year,
three weeks out of the month,
12 months out of the year, for 11 years.
Needless to say, I experienced burnout.
I got to the point where I was like,
"I can't do this anymore."
But I liked what I did.
But I can't do it anymore.
But I like what I do.
I can't do it anymore.
So I was experiencing burnout.
In order to not have to
give up what I liked doing,
I said "Well, what is it
that brought me to this work?
Why did I want to do
this in the first place?"
Because, at Home care, at Homebridge,
we provide home care providers
this training, because when I started,
there was no training for these workers.
And we were asking them to go out
and care for some very
challenging individuals.
One of the things about Homebridge
is our clients that we care for
are some of the most
challenging individuals
in the city and county of San Francisco.
And yet we were sending out workers
to care for them with
very little experience.
And the other side of it
that really got to me,
was that, we were having these
clients being taken care of
by people who didn't know
what they were doing.
That to me was really frightening.
So, I said "Yes, I wanna train them,
I have the expertise to do this.
I have the passion to do this.
I'm going to do this. I like doing this"
And I did for quite some time,
and I did it very well, and
I still do it very well.
But that's why I came to the work.
I wanted to be able to teach
the home care providers
how to care for people,
how to care for them so they
could change their lives,
so they could make them happy,
so they could put a smile on their face.
That's where my inspiration came from.
And so, returning to those
thoughts, and to those feelings,
I found myself, resilient, rejuvenated.
The inspiration came back to me.
And I also did some practical things.
I went to Matt, who was my boss,
and I said, "Hey, I think I'm burnt out."
And, we were able to develop a plan
where I was able to reduce
my time in the classroom
and I was given the opportunity
to start developing and
rewriting some of our curriculum,
and developing curriculum for some of
the other programs in Homebridge.
And that's another passion of mine,
something that inspires me, is writing.
So suddenly, I could
feel myself rejuvenated,
feeling more excited about going to work,
and not experiencing the burnout.
But where it started was
going back to where I began.
Where did I find my inspiration?
So that's my story, I'm gonna stick to it,
and I'm gonna turn it back over to Matt,
and let him finish up.
Thank you for listening.
(clapping)
- Okay, thanks Dennis.
Are we on my slide? Thank you, Dennis.
So, I thought I'd dovetail that
and give a little bit of what inspires me,
and I was thinking about this
as we were talking about this
for the past three or four months,
I'm like "What inspires
me in what I'm doing?"
I continually went back to
when I was graduating from high school
in a very small town in Illinois.
Actually, we lived outside
of town, in the country,
and my dad owned a junkyard,
and being a gay man I had
no desire to work on cars
or do anything that would get me dirty.
So my dad said "Well,
you need to get a job,
so go get a job at the county home,"
the nursing home, which is
about two miles up the road.
I'm like, "Oh, that can't be too hard."
So when I got there, the D.O.N. said,
"You're going up on the unit for
the retarded people and the mongoloids."
I'm like, "Oh, okay."
I didn't even know much
about what that was.
When I got up there, though,
it was a unit of 20 people and me,
and that was it, that was the ratio.
But I found two brothers
in a room together
that were the brothers of our neighbors
that I knew for my entire life,
and I never knew that
she had two brothers who had disabilities.
And I worked there for four years,
and I kept thinking,
"There's gotta be a better
way for these people."
There must be a better
place for these people,
they're not sick!
So after I graduated from college,
I ended up starting to work
at a local ark organization,
and one of the things that I did
in those four years I was there,
was Illinois was faced with a lawsuit
to get people with disabilities
out of nursing homes,
and one of my proudest moments
was when those two brothers
moved into an eight bedroom
home with roommates,
and they still live there today,
and they're not living in a nursing home,
and the family brings them
home now for Christmas,
they don't ignore them.
So I've changed some lives there.
That, always, is my inspiration
for everything that I've done.
The next 20 years of
my career was dedicated
to moving people out
of restrictive settings
and into a setting that
they wanted to live in,
and that's what I'm always inspired by.
Thank you.
(clapping)
So, inspiration, I think,
what I wanted to talk about,
what do I want to say
about how to be inspired?
Well, I guess I wanna
say don't overthink it.
I found some interesting information
on a website called lifehack.org,
and there's basically
four points with 12 tips
on just easy things that you should do
that's always going to help you
to stay inspired and be productive.
One area is to stay healthy.
These are pretty simple things.
Drink a glass of water when
you wake up in the morning.
I drink a glass of orange
juice, but water works too.
Another suggestion is to
move and sweat, exercise.
Obviously, that's, as Dennis mentioned,
that's the hardest one to stick to.
I'm notorious for signing up
at every gym every year in January
and I quit that gym in, like, March.
But I'm glad that I can support
their capital investment by
giving them lots of money
to keep their equipment up to
date because I don't use it.
Getting sleep.
Making sure that you're rested.
Last night, it was the hardest time.
Our roommates are getting
married this morning
and I will never hear the end of it
that I'm not there at their wedding,
at city hall,
but I had to go to sleep last night
while they were all hooting and hollering
and getting excited about today.
But it always makes you more
productive the next day.
Planning your day.
You should try and think of three tasks
that you want to achieve that day.
They can be little ones,
they can be big ones,
doesn't matter.
But the important thing there is
to kind of mentally have in your mind
that probably those things
won't all get achieved,
if you're like me.
So having a plan on, like,
what are you gonna do,
what's the backup plan if
you don't achieve all those?
There's a thing called the 50/10 rules,
so you should work on some project,
whatever your work is
for about 50 minutes,
but then take a ten
minute break from that,
whether it's a true break,
or just to go do something else,
maybe check email, if you're like us,
I have about 20 emails
that pop up every hour in my email box.
So, don't do something
unhealthy like I used to do,
and go out and have a
cigarette for ten minutes.
That's not a healthy option.
Another thing is to reflect on your day.
So at the end of the day,
reflecting on what you have achieved,
or a self evaluation of yourself.
I encourage you just
to take time to think.
One of the things I do when I get home
is I just kind of go into our den
and just kind of think about the day,
and there's no goal there, of like,
to write down what I achieved.
Just process it.
If you devote some time to
that, it really does work.
Another thing is to keep learning.
Reading, whether that's an actual book,
or on an iPad or whatever.
Always increasing your knowledge.
Browsing, staying in touch with tutorials,
or conducting research,
or attending conferences like this.
These can be very rejuvenating for you.
Brainstorm.
Think about, just brainstorming
can be a creative goldmine,
just a kind of data dump of
stuff that you wanna try and do.
Okay.
And focus on what makes you happy.
Express gratitude.
Think about ten things every morning
that you're grateful for.
It's easier than you think.
I came up with five
that just associated with
being alive again today,
waking up, not dead.
So it's pretty easy to do that part.
Clean your desk,
at your work, or at your home in your den.
Keep it tidy.
If you're obsessive like me,
that's an easy one.
I always do that, it's kind of
up there with making my bed.
And then also, indulging
in some favorite things.
Setting time aside to relax
and enjoy things that you like to do,
whether that's playing with your pet,
or whatever.
Here in the Bay Area,
we're very fortunate,
there's lots and lots of parks
and things to go on walks.
But it's easy to forget
to try and do that.
For me personally, and my partner,
we had been sucked into the daily drama
of what our current president is doing
and it's hard.
So we have now limited ourselves
to one hour of MSNBC a night,
although last night was pushing two,
just because it was a
new chapter in craziness.
Anyway, so those are just some things
that I thought would be
helpful to share with you.
As we talked about closing today,
we wanted to close with something
that's also inspirational.
Before I came to Homebridge,
I had the opportunity
to work for an organization
called Creativity Explored.
It's based here in San Francisco.
It is a program for adults with
developmental disabilities.
It's a visual art studio and gallery.
When I came there,
I had left the world of
residential back in 2007,
and dipped my feet into adult day services
and employment training,
and landed at Creativity Explored,
not knowing anything about art.
But this, tied with my story
from back when I graduated from college,
keeps me inspired.
And I go back to Creativity Explored
when they have openings
for new exhibitions,
but it's truly an inspiring thing to see
what these people do.
So, with the permission
of that organization,
I'm gonna show you a video
that they used last year
at their fundraising gala,
so you can kind of ignore
the fact at the end,
that it talks about supporting them.
But I thought the video is a great way
to kinda close this morning
up, and we hope you enjoy it.
(inspirational music)
- [Angela] Does Corinne think
of herself as an artist?
Corinne thinks of herself
as being the paint.
- [Lollie] From day
one, Roland was hooked.
He loves it.
And when he can't go
to Creativity Explored,
he is not a happy camper.
And neither am I!
- [Maron] This is special because
it gives my brother the
opportunity to be something
in his life that he never before was.
- [Angela] We knew early on,
that she was gonna need care 24 hours.
So if she's living with us,
and we're working everyday,
what's Corinne gonna do?
We really didn't know what
her future was gonna be.
- [Maron] In my country,
it's not opportunity, zero opportunity,
for people like my brother.
- [Lollie] I'm so fortunate
to live in this city
that has a lot of resources
for people like Roland.
Without it, I don't know.
- [Lisa] For anyone who is caregiving
for someone with a
developmental disability,
they want their family member
to have a good life.
And if you're able to be expressive,
and be in a positive environment
for the majority of your day,
that's gonna happen.
- [Paul] Yeah, Roland doesn't say a lot.
It's more of the action,
and it's more like
how he does things.
- [Eric] He's got these really
intensely detailed grid network of lines.
- [Lollie] What it means
exactly, I'm not sure,
except that, that's how
he expresses himself.
- [Paul] So Corrine,
there's such a passion
in the sketches and drawings,
and this energy that she
creates on these pieces
that doesn't matter so much
that she doesn't say
anything in these words.
She speaks in other ways.
- [Angela] I feel that socially,
she's accepted, finally,
in the environment that
creativity gives her.
- [Paul] It's almost like a miracle,
some of the things that their children
or their siblings start doing here.
- [Eric] So the disability thing
really fades to the background,
and what we try to enhance is
what people are able to do,
what their abilities are.
- [Lollie] I was so worried about
what kind of life we were
gonna have when he was born,
and now he's a collectible artist?
Oh my god.
That's fantastic.
- [Maron] It gives him a little freedom
because in his entire life,
he never earned the kind of money
that he earned in this program.
- [Angela] I don't know if she
understands the word Pride,
I just know that as long
as she can be the paint
and the brush, she is happy.
(inspiring music)
(clapping)
- Does anybody need a tissue?
So, again, thank you so much
for getting up so early
and coming and listening to us.
We hope that we have inspired you,
that you now have some
resilience in your life.
Because, you know, I think
just seeing the video,
you can see, this is
where the inspiration is.
But we wanted to close with a quote,
from the renowned
theologian and philosopher,
Albert Schweitzer.
He once said,
and he was saying this actually to youth.
He said "I don't know
what your destiny will be,
but one thing I do know,
the only ones among you
who will be really happy,
are those who have sought
and found how to serve."
So thank you for serving.
(clapping)